hockey canada tente de se sortir la tête
de l'eau après deux mois de scandale
pour avoir réglé à l'amiable une
poursuite pour un présumé viol collectif
la plus grande fédération sportive du
pays présente un plan d'action la
fédération s'engagent à adopter la plus
récente version du code de conduite
universel pour contrer la maltraitance
hanquez canada veut aussi mettre en
place un système de signalement et de
suivi des plaintes et améliorer la
formation des joueurs et des entraîneurs
ce qui était l'innovateur en trop dedans
c'est vraiment le fait qu'en france on
annonce qu'on va repenser la mission de
raki canada les valeurs qui étaient
traditionnellement plus axée autour de
la compétition de la passion la
présentation d'un tel plan d'action fait
partie des conditions du gouvernement
fédéral pour le dégel de ces fonds en
canada a reçu 14 millions de dollars
d'ottawa en 2020 et 2021 je pense que
c'était un incontournable alors oui je
crois que lille devait le faire et je
crois que il savait que la commission
parlementaire a élevé à grands pas la
confiance de parents de joueurs
demeurent et branly certains croient que
le plan n'est pas crédible ils sont en
réaction avec ce que les journalistes
ont trouvé henry tulle déposer un tel
blain minutes et eu des enquêtes de la
prime est ok canada dévoile son plan
d'action à la veille de la reprise des
audiences au comité permanent du
patrimoine canadien à ottawa la ministre
des sports pascal saintonge et le
directeur financier d'ing canada sont
parmi les personnes convoquées des
questions sur le fond de réserve de
hacker canada pour régler des cas
d'agression sexuelle pourrait être posée
ici charlotte dumoulin radio canada
montréal